i i mean you [ __ ] telescope your  butthole i do but i only go like this  much time out you telescope your body  he's cleaning the inside of your head  cleans his ass he sticks his finger in  and he telescopes it every single time  so it's really super clean he's really  good too that's the farthest i can ever  go is like my as soon as my fingernail  touches it it [ __ ] hurts you gotta  relax you gotta blow out it doesn't have  to be that clean  is there inspections no i hate itchy  butt i try to like go  way far and beyonce i never have itchy  but the whole day not even an itchy  large intestine yeah bart lives the most  optimal life everything he does is for  optimal performance  he does the extra miles  that's also why i break [ __ ] too  rwanda's plan to increase pork  production  [Music]